taking aim at an enemy who's not yet on
their streets but soon could be
with a state of emergency pending the
threat from russia feels closer by the
day
demand for personal weapons is also
soaring in kiev
this man didn't want to speak on camera
but he said he's buying his first rifle
to better protect his family
as for anatoly this was a birthday
present from his wife
target practice
nope
[Music]
there's been a rise of between 100 and
200
in the number of people coming to use
this shooting range since december with
all slots booked out a manager says it's
because civilians in kiev are getting
ready to fight if they have to
it's a prospect that became more real as
the president's top security official
revealed plans for the state of
emergency they're set to be approved by
parliament and could include
restrictions on travel and curfews
the british foreign secretary today says
that she believes it's highly likely
there will be a russian attack on kiev
do you share that assessment
the president hosting the heads of
poland and lithuania still hopes
diplomacy can work
but with russia ordering troops into
separatist held parts of ukraine and
massing forces around the border he's
now calling up reservists to bolster his
defenses
at a local government office in the
capital the young and old offer their
services with varying degrees of
enthusiasm
foreign
back at the gun shop the national flag
sums up the mood
as they await president putin's next
move debrahing sky news kiev